let me ask you about religion because I
think one of the First videos that I saw
of you many many moons ago probably
around 2017 or something like that when
you were just getting started and using
YouTube you were talking about religion
and God
um I can't remember the exact words but
I mean you were talking something along
the lines of like you know like why like
you know put yourself first like you
know is this even real sort of thing so
you sort of came off more as a atheist
or agnostic then you kind of went to
um Christianity you know with Romania
I've heard you talk about making large
donations to the church sort of thing
and now you've converted to Islam can
you explain why you've kind of shifted
your mindset and your beliefs from more
like non
non-religious to Christianity to Islam
and why absolutely absolutely so first
things first it is a very rare
occurrence I am wrong but I will admit
it I was wrong I know mind bending I was
wrong I truly didn't believe that God
existed but then
it became more and more apparent to me
that he must exist because Newton's
third law is equal in opposite Force
when he sat underneath the apple tree he
talked about the three laws of gravity
and the three laws of motion and one of
them was equal and opposite Force if
there's a force in One Direction there
must be an equal and opposite force in
the opposite direction and if you look
at the world today and understand that
people like valenciaga people who are
reporting these ideals on children
people who are trying to chop
everybody's dicks off people who are
trying to make you do the injections you
don't need if you're looking at this and
understanding this is the work of demons
this is the work of the devil these
people are truly evil there must be an
equal and opposite force and that equal
and opposite force is God there's no
other way for it to there's no other way
to explain it besides the fact there's
so much evil in the world I've seen the
enough evil and seen enough of Satan to
understand that God must exist so yes
once I understood that God must be real
I I naturally revert it to Christianity
because it's the country I live in and
it's the third most religious country on
the planet Romania third most Christian
country on the planet I apologize
Vatican City is is technically number
one the Vatican number two is a very
small island somewhere in the Southeast
Pacific but Romania at 99.7 Christian is
the third most religious uh Christianity
religious country in the world and I and
I had respect for for Christianity but
truthfully I don't think there's any
other religion than Islam and the reason
for that is just simply because I
believe God should be feared and I think
only the god well I think there's one
God there's maybe different
interpretations but there's only one God
but the different
interpretations of of said God I think
it should be the one that is most
fearsome God is going to be a fierce
it's going to be a feared individual God
is going to be somebody who you do not
want to cross or upset and I think that
Islam describes him best so I understood
first that God must be real and I've
always had healthy respect for Islam and
it was just a matter of me going through
my own personal journey to find a
religion that that
was easiest for me to respect almost
because I think that how can you worship
or believe in something you don't
respect and if you look at a lot of the
garbage coming out about Christian
preachers Now in America who are trans
and Christian preachers with with gay
flags on the church and all this
Insanity I think that Christianity has
lost its way so if I believe in God and
Christianity has lost this way then I've
been shown the truth and the truth must
be in love hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and say
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out